Wow this is natural lighting really does
the trick I'm floored floor
hello st. Patrick's Day is next Tuesday
March 17th and I don't exactly know who
celebrates st. Patrick's Day
internationally I'm up here in Canada
and I asked some local Canadians if they
celebrated Saint Patrick's Day and they
said no we celebrate st. Patrick's a
look regardless today I'm making a video
in which st. Patrick's Day is the
central topic st. Patrick's Day is a day
that everyone pretends to be Irish and
gets really drunk and makes bad choices
yeah there's a lot of like politically
incorrect undertones and overtones and
just tones and it's okay because it's a
holiday if you make a bad choice on a
holiday doesn't play count right it's
like multiplying two negatives equals
positive wear protection today I'm
giving you some Saint Patrick's Day
party decorating ideas one of the new
sensations of society is photo booths
with props a wedding isn't a wedding
anymore unless it has a photo booth with
a variety of props that you hold up to
your face - I - look quirky photo booths
with props give everyone a sense of
humor so I'm going to show you how you
can make props for a st. Patrick's Day
themed photo booth and how you can make
a garland then how you can make some
sort of garland banner Saint Patrick's
Day party decor thing let's get started
here's what you'll need scissors
popsicle sticks tiny clothes pins and
markers and foam craft paper and glue
and strength first thing we're gonna do
is start making the props for the
photobooth now this is entirely up to
you you can make whatever you goddamn
feel but
I have a couple ideas in mind and I'm
going to show you how to make those and
you can make your own spin on them
because I don't know and you know not
even not at all
I whoa we're gonna take one of our foam
sheets when you think about st.
Patrick's Day immediately you think
about human vomit so I'm gonna make a
little fake vomit now I'm figuring this
out as I go like the first time someone
has sex and they take my marker and I
want the moment to look like it's
spewing from someone's mouth so I'm
gonna kind of trace what I think the
vomit would look like this is
essentially just a giant amoeba shape
and/or a series of flaccid dicks going
together there we go see that so now
we're gonna color it in with what we
think would be vomit colors here's some
Browns and maybe some greens remember
human vomit is like snowflakes no two
are exactly the same and there's my
final product now I'm gonna cut it out
our vomit is cut out how perfect now
we're gonna take our that there's a
popsicle stick we're into our popsicle
stick and glue it to the back of the
vomit or tape it whatever is easiest for
you so that essentially when someone
takes photos they can hold it up to
their mouth like opera glasses okay BAM
we let the glue dry on that guy and
we're gonna go ahead and make some other
props for our st. Patrick's Day photo
booth BRB okay so I'm done for the
moment making my Photo Booth props I've
made a sign that says mistake and I've
made glasses that are just drunk
eyeballs yeah so they're gonna continue
to dry and now we're gonna move on to
our garland and essentially our garland
is just a smaller version of our bark
we're gonna take another piece of our
foam sheet and we're gonna make smaller
little bar
icons encourage you to vary up the puke
icons with a rainbow of colors it'll
look cuter and more true to life because
I don't know if you ate confetti cake
before you came to my party okay all of
our pukes have been colored in and now
to the annoying part which is cutting
them out so all of my pukes have been
cut out now what I'm going to do is take
my twine use as much twine as you want
the length of your banner garland to be
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
attach these puke cutouts to our twine
using these teeny tiny [ __ ] adorable
clothespins you can't see anything I'm
doing this is the perfect angle very
great at crafts videos go get on the
string we have our st. Patrick's Day
puke Garland's let's hang it up and see
how it looks with our photo booth
well there you go guys there are my tips
for some fun st. Patrick's Day party
decoration ideas I hope that you have a
really great syntactic today please
drink responsibly that's the only
serious part of this video I don't know
I couldn't even wait what was that
okay now that over the blue path damnit
good you I watched your video Jenna I
loved it one of my favorite feelings is
confusion followed by pure elation of
things making sense
rock and roll girl